All right, let's hear from some folks in our
audience.
It's been another busy week and I want to
see what's on your mind.
We are now taking calls via discord.
You can join the discord at David Pakman dotcom
slash discord.
Very, very exciting things happening there.
I think we have maybe even breached 7000 discord
members.
And it only launched I think it was like somewhere
between two days and seven months ago.
So that's that's a lot.
Let's go first to Tim from Boston.
We'll take a local call.
Tim from Boston.
What's going on?
Hey, Dave.
Yeah, where are you?
Are you at Fenway?
How is it that they set for it?
I've actually never been.
Yeah, David.
Hey, so thanks for taking my call.
So, you know, we saw some big wins for our
direct democracy with all the ballot initiatives
during the election.
But I really want to know your opinion on
the efficacy of this new form of direct democracy
that's becoming popular.
I'm working on a website called Terk that
I o that's t you are cute, Orio.
This website enables everyday people to collaborate
on writing citizen legislation that then gets
submitted to various legislatures.
The ideas that this former director democracy
isn't people voting on every issue, rather
people everyday people having a hand in the
actual writing of the law.
What are your thoughts on the efficacy of
citizens having a hand in the drafting of
the actual law?
And given the fact is that given the fact
that I don't know anything about this website,
are you affiliated with this website?
Yes, sir, you are.
OK, so in the future I would mention that
up front because that it makes it sketchy.
When I have to I have to figure out that you're
actually affiliated with the website, even
though it was kind of obvious because you
were like reading off of it, you know.
Oh, my apologies.
Yeah, I would try to make sure I am associated
with a website so I know nothing about the
website.
Here's what I would say.
Given that 72 million people thought it was
a good idea to vote for Donald Trump, I question
whether letting random people write laws is
a good idea.
I am very much for ballot initiatives.
I am very much for restructuring our system
from the standpoint of campaign finance, ranked
choice voting and all of these other things,
letting random people write laws.
To me, there's a lot of questions around that.
I want to think more about it.
Yeah, I mean, we see that with open source
software all the time, where we let all kinds
of people participate in running open source
software, we do.
I think the stakes are maybe a little different,
though, between making law and writing software.
Well, a lot of open source software is actually
used to keep airplanes in the sky and things
like that.
So a lot of our infrastructure, both from
safety and financial reasons and all kinds
of ways, open source software as leverage
to for those.
So the idea is that, you know, citizens, if
there's a technology check so that terms of
service are met and only the best quality
legislation is actually pulled in and put
to use the same way that we process as we
see in open source and open source software.
Excuse me.
Yeah, I mean, I think, again, the difference
with software is to even participate in that
process.
You need to know how to write software.
And the difference would be any random person
might say, hey, yeah, I want to I want to
write law.
I think it's an interesting idea.
I want to increase the way I want to.
I want to increase the connection so that
our our elected officials more accurately
reflect the desires of the people that I do
want, whether it's letting random people write
law I'm unsure of.
But I appreciate the question.
Yeah, absolutely.
Thanks, David.
Just a quick plug to to to say that the number
of people that each individual representative
has to count for legislation or increases
every day.
So that's another reason why this idea of
an alternative direct democracy, where the
people can actually participate in writing
the laws or the legislation for the things
that impact them is an idea that isn't isn't
something I came up with.
You know, I'm affiliated with this one website.
God's concept of get laws is pretty popular.
Got it.
All right.
Very good.
I will evaluate its popularity.
There is Tim from Boston.
Let's go next to Becky from Birmingham.
Now, is this Birmingham, England, or Birmingham,
Alabama?
Oh, hello, David Sario, it's Birmingham in
the UK.
Oh, it is OK.
I was expecting a completely different accent.
No, no, definitely the Lucy voice, if you
hear Alousi voice is Birmingham in England.
So it's now just really quickly.
So I've got two real questions here for you
is our government have recently voted against
feeding disadvantaged children during the
school holidays as well as open in all the
schools around the country, almost like a
petri dish for the virus to just mutai around
children.
How are any of these choices that government
to make and how are they helping at the moment?
And have you seen anything similar at the
moment in the United States, in the neighboring
states, in terms of taking care of kids who
are depending on on being in school for something
like just even having meals every day, you're
saying?
Yes, I suppose so.
We have things here called free school meals,
so similar to when children go to school in
the US and have their meals there as well.
Right.
It's that sort of a feeling, really, that
they've not helped out for the disadvantaged
children who maybe don't have their laptops
at home to work from home or maybe don't have
the necessary food allowance to be able to
buy that much food for a week.
I mean, unfortunately, there's been no well-organized
federal effort to do that here in the United
States.
Unfortunately, we have this disgusting reality
in the US where it's one of the richest countries
in the world.
And yet you still have many kids who are going
to bed hungry.
You have many kids who are counting on getting
a free lunch or a reduced price lunch at school
when there's no school because of the pandemic.
What do they do now?
There have been some local efforts and I don't
have a list in front of me.
But there is there have been local efforts
at the municipality level, maybe even some
at the state level, although I'm not sure
to continue providing the lunches, even if
there is no school.
And I think that that's a great thing better
would be to solve this problem where why do
we have hunger in a country as rich as the
United States?
But unfortunately, nothing, nothing structural
and and federally organized has been done
on that.
It's pretty sad.
It's the same sort of thing here as well.
There's actually a famous footballer.
I don't know if it's hit the news over in
the US as well.
A footballer by the name of Marcus Rashford
has been campaigning for free school meals
around the UK at the moment to make sure that
these children are actually getting fed.
They are actually being able to learn on a
full stomach rather than being extremely great
during that time.
And so there is little things going on like
that.
But the government of just declined it really
and said, nope, we're not doing that.
We'll just throw that to the salad.
I do think there are some European countries
that have better dealt with some of these
issues.
But but again, you know, I, I don't have details
in front of me because I never know what people
are going to ask about.
But it is a real tragedy that this is going
on in so many different places.
Yeah, definitely.
Well, it has been absolutely fantastic to
speak to you.
What do you think the outcome is just in general
of what what could happen in these situations?
Now, just a brief overview of those.
The children never get fed.
Will they ever go back to school properly?
Yeah, they will go back to school.
They will go back to school, but then we'll
go back to still having all of the problems
we had when the pandemic hit.
So there's a lot of work certainly, certainly
to do.
And a bigger topic for, you know, an entire
show about education, quite frankly.
But, Becky, I really appreciate you calling
in today.
No worries at all.
It's been lovely to speak to somebody who
knows what they're talking about.
So thank you.
Likewise.
Same same on this side of the microphone.
Very much appreciate that.